Imagine what it would be like to have a
miniature version of our son right here
on earth with this artificial star.
Provide us with an infinite supply of
clean energy. What do we even need?
All the coal and nuclear power plants
that give us electricity today.
Could the energy from a mini sun replace
rocket fuel and could we control it?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we
built a replica of the sun on Earth.
The Sun is an enormous nuclear
fusion generator. Every second.
It fuses 620 million tons of hydrogen
into 606 million tons of helium in its
core,
releasing a vast amount of energy in the
process to create a replica of the sun
on Earth. We just need to squeeze atoms
of hydrogen hard enough to make them.
Fuse shouldn't be too hard, right? Well,
this fusion is only possible
at extreme temperatures.
Even the sun's coldest part.
It's surface burns at an
incredible 5,500 degrees.
Not even a space suit can protect
you from that kind of heat,
but we could engineer a high temperature
super conductor to tame our scorching
mini sun. What would it take to bring
this brighter future into reality?
Having an artificial sun on our hands
would provide us with almost limitless
amounts of energy. Of course, it
would be much smaller than the sun.
Our replica could fit inside a machine
the size of 60 football fields and would
have the weight of three Eiffel Towers.
To make it work,
we'd need to specific hydrogen isotopes.
One of them called Deuterium.
We'd extract from water.
The other one Tridium we'd brew from
Lithium during the fusion reaction itself,
we'd give them any sun, its own magnetic
field with the help of huge magnets,
at least a thousand times more powerful
than those you put on your fridge.
This field would keep the artificial sun
in place while we're heating it up to
150 million degrees.
Few materials could handle the
scorching plasma of our son.
We'd have to create a
robust blanket for it,
one that wouldn't melt
during the scorching fusion.
Once we had all the
engineering issues figured out,
the artificial sun would completely
change the way our energy system works.
It wouldn't admit any greenhouse
gases and there would be no hazardous
radioactive waste left to the case.
Slowly over a thousand years,
unlike fossil fuels,
we'd never run out of hydrogen,
the most common element in the universe.
With this clean and safe source of energy,
we'd stop adding fuel to climate change
and maybe give our planet a second
chance.
Next,
we'd build fusion engines
for our spacecraft and go
on to explore space faster
than we ever imagined with hot
plasma fueling up our rockets,
it would take us just
30 days to get to Mars.
Huge progress compared to a nine month
trip with our current technology.
Sound like science fiction.
What if I told you,
physicists around the world have been
working on recreating a miniature star for
decades. We already have reactors
capable of producing some like fusion,
but so far none of them have produced
more energy than they needed to consume to
make this reaction happen
in the first place.
Everything could change with a new class
of high temperature superconductors
that would bring nuclear fusion from an
expensive science experiment to a viable
source of energy available to everyone.
By the time scientists figure it out,
we may have moved off earth
and onto the nearest planet,
but that's a story for another.
What if.